la France c'est tout à la fois c'est
tous les Français
c'est par la gauche la France c'est pas
la droite la France ce que nous voulons
ça n'est pas rassembler la gauche
ça n'est pas rassembler la droite
[Applaudissements]
c'est rassemblés les Français
l'Orchestre de Paris joue maintenant
l'hymne à la joie le président de la
République va se recueillir devant les
tombeaux de Jean Jaurès et du résistant
Jean Moulin
une arrivée seule à pied une longue
traversée de la cour de l'ancien palais
royal
au son de l'hymne à la joie l'hymne
européen il rejoint ses partisans le
décor est grandiose
[Musique]
on attendait l'événement depuis
plusieurs jours à Chamalières le match
de football entre les commerçants de la
ville et l'équipe du conseil municipal
avec le maire de Sète bien sûr monsieur
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing fidèle au
rendez-vous de ce dimanche matin coup de
théâtre à une minute de la fin à la
suite d'une action confuse devant les
buts commerçants l'arbitre accordé un
penalty à la mairie le premier magistrat
n'allait les laisser à personne le soin
de faire justice
et devinez quoi il a tiré en plein
milieu ni à droite ni à gauche je sais
que vous avez pas mal d'analystes
politiques en plateau qui vont pouvoir
analyser ce penalty sur le fond en tout
cas voilà le gardien a touché le ballon
et Emmanuel Macron a pu marquer le but
[Musique]